Ramanujan is an inspirational figure
after all and he's the topic of a
popular Hollywood film now the man who
knew infinity but he's much more than an
inspirational figure to me he's been
he's been a guardian angel to me and as
impossible as that might sound to
believe I have to tell you he was the
news of Ramanujan was very important to
me as a 16 year old you know as a 16
year old high schooler I was trained
that I was trained to believe that to be
successful you had to be a perfect
straight-a student you had to get you
know perfect test scores of course
they're important but mrs. Ramanujan
wrote a letter to my father in 1984 when
I was in tenth grade over 60 years after
Ramanujan died and that's when I first
learned about this great genius who was
not well known for grades if anything he
was well known for being a 2-time
college dropout but a real artist a
genius someone whose mathematical ideas
were pure flights of fancy I learned
about him again in college when the Nova
special about him came out and professor
Paul sali one of my most important
mentors in my life came along and and we
talked about Ramanujan and importance of
his ideas and then of course in graduate
school when the book the man who knew
infinity came out I together with my
adviser basil Gordon we read it and we
got a lot of strength out of at least
certainly I did and certainly at those
three points in my life as a high school
student and a college student later as a
graduate student I needed to be reminded
and reassured that the time was going to
come that I would be evaluated
professionally for my achievement not
test scores and not grades and in that
way I think he's been my guardian angel
and you know and and and in my work I've
been following him professionally and
it's worked out very well for me